i can't even begin to tell you how happy
i am to see you and
i guess that's your dog too that's
douglas that's one of one half of my
uh amazing dog family you have to have
good dogs around now i'm a big dog
person i have i have three rescues and
two other dogs so
we love our dogs and they're just
fantastic they just are the best so when
i saw that you had your dog in your set
i was like this is good
well one of the only coveted safe people
to have around
that's true he's in my pod he's safe he
can come on
bring that energy in life um although he
looks like he's nodding out right now
um no it's game show week here on the
show
and you guys got to do the price is
right with
the whole seal team cast was it as fun
as it looked and you got to touch that
wheel tell me everything
it's pretty amazing you know when you go
into there and drew obviously was
fantastic he's awesome
and but when you go into that energy it
is
it pulls you right in you feel like
you're in this just
um almost kind of like moulin rouge kind
of scene the lights and the and the game
show and the audiences it's
you kind of feed off that energy and be
able to spin that wheel
like as a kid i remember being at my
best friend joey sapphire's house and
buffalo going
i would watch the prices right every day
in buffalo new york be like
that would be the show to be on and i
was like i couldn't believe it i was
like i'm
actually going to touch and spin the
wheel but uh i was amazed just by the
energy
of the people that are there and having
a good time so it was a lot of fun and
we raised a lot of money for
a charity called headstrong so we were
really proud to do it was it was a great
time
i think that i've had a real revelation
about game shows doing this this week
because we just thought it's so fun
i've been such a fan of them growing up
but when you break down
the positivity and psychology and
potential winnings and being on tv and
just
the whole as you said energy of it
i never realized why game shows are so
important and they're an amazing
business they've been on 30 40 50 years
it's huge you know like from tic-tac-toe
to to
tic-tac-toe martindale right it was like
that was what i grew up with it was like
hey eggo waffles
in front of the tv or no deal whatever
that is it's like
watching these game shows and you're
like okay it's the afternoon time to
have a grilled cheese sandwich go for a
swim
yes yes and like a ten thousand dollar
pyramid
and no whammies no wambies and stuff
and they must have had a deal with the
extopa like
exchange bureau because everybody took a
trip to ixtapa
perfect segway your mom is a travel
agent
she yeah she was a travel agent and um
you know
growing up you know with her being a
travel agent you knew like you were
gonna get some pretty cool
um ideas on where to travel but yet then
again we'd all stuffed in
in the station wagon and just drive to
toronto that was our vacation
i've been driven to rv around america
like several times i love road trips
there's something though when you're a
kid you're like 11 years old or
something you just you'd get car sick or
the smell of the leather i don't know
there's something there that was kind of
bizarre
when you were traveling couldn't wait to
get there it's like you know i remember
i lost my i forgot my suitcase i got to
toronto i had no clothes my parents had
to buy me clothes it was disaster that
was not a
that's not a good way to start the trip
you got like a roots
sweatsuit and just called it a day it
was just off
it was i don't know what it was but you
know my mom was
like you know how could you forget your
suitcase and then we drove back
after being there in toronto for four
days and there was my suitcase in the
driveway
did she ever send you somewhere that you
liked
did she ever recommend somewhere that
you were like mom
it's not what you think it is or
anything i just i'm such a travel junkie
i remember being in dublin and traveling
in ireland and
she gave me some good insight into some
castles to go to which was amazing
i mean if anyone has the opportunity to
go to ireland i would
recommend it the cliffs of mar it's just
it's such a gorgeous beautiful
area but yeah she gave me some insights
and some castles to go to
i love that and i think that what your
mom
has done and what we all miss so much
you know is just some trips maybe seeing
that's right and just like some human
contact and being able to
have some coffee outside and then go for
a walk and hopefully
soon we will be able to merge back into
the lifestyle we kind of knew
while we are stuck in our homes thank
god
for people like you and shows like seal
team
our tv is our family and our comfort so
you've been there
for everybody for a long time and thank
goodness that you are
there and um it's really appreciated
well thank you right back at you what
you're doing on the show is fantastic
it's great and you're going to people's
homes and so god bless you
well thank you david borean is the
season 4 of seal team airs wednesday at
9
on cbs thank you so much david
you